Vin Diesel has a Trilogy of sci-fi
action movies sitting in the top 10 on
Netflix one of which was made over 20
years ago but as ridiculous as it may
sound there's a simple reason for the
franchise's uptick in popularity despite
being involved in some of the biggest
franchises of the 21st century Vin
Diesel has rarely seen eye to eye with
critics while the actor drew some
Acclaim for early roles in films like
The Iron Giant and Saving Private Ryan
subsequent efforts such as a Man Apart
The Pacifier and knock around guys were
largely dismissed as empty action
Vehicles still that hasn't slowed diesel
down one bit as the actor has been
working steadily on dozens of projects
over the last 25 years furthermore Die
Hard fans of Diesel's work in a long
dormant science fiction franchise have
seen a loose-fitting Trilogy of the
actor's films returning to the Limelight
as strange as it is Richard B Riddick
has emerged from the darkness and is
currently overshadowing much of the
competition on Netflix currently all
three films in David tui's dark
futuristic science fiction Thriller
series are sitting pretty in Netflix's
top 10 list of movies a fact that
probably has a lot to do with ongoing
rumors that diesel will be returning to
the franchise to reunite with Tui yet
again the Riddick franchise launched
back in 2000 with its first entry pitch
black the film saw a group of survivors
attempting to navigate a mysterious
alien world filled with deadly nocturnal
creatures after the ship crash lands
ironically prisoner and serial killer
Richard B Riddick who possesses the
unique ability to see in the dark
becomes the only person who might be
able to lead the group to safety causing
the survivors to reluctantly release him
I am worth twice as much alive
since the character took off in
popularity following pitch black many
spin-off projects were put into the
works a sequel came in the form of The
Chronicles of Riddick while an animated
short film The Chronicles of Riddick
dark Fury filled in the story between
the two movies elsewhere two
well-received video games filled in
other parts of the character's
mysterious backstory The Chronicles of
Riddick escaped from butcher Bay showed
how Riddick broke out of prison prior to
being caught by a bounty hunter and
placed on the ship from Pitch Black
meanwhile The Chronicles of Riddick
assault on Dark Athena sees the
character trying to battle his way out
of a mercenary ship finally there was
Riddick in 2013. the film took the
character Back to Basics by having him
fight for his life on a hostile Planet
full of deadly alien creatures of the
three main movies this one is currently
the highest in the Netflix top 10 with
Chronicles of Riddick and Pitch Black
showing up in descending order a fourth
Mainline Riddick movie was confirmed
recently with both writer director David
Tui and franchise starved Vin Diesel set
to return titled Riddick 4 Furia the
film will purportedly see the character
who is the last surviving member of an
alien race called The furians Returned
to his home planet according to Tui the
film will reveal that Riddick is
actually not the last of the furians Tui
has also said that the survivors are
very much alike to Diesel's character a
factor that will probably either see him
team up with them against external
forces or set up a fury and Battle
Royale between many of the gruffvoiced
human hybrids while more concrete
details like returning cast members or a
release date are still incoming the cult
following of the franchise will no doubt
be spreading the word that the property
is returning hence the sudden uptick in
interest in the series on Netflix
whether this one can finally impress
critics however remains to be seen
foreign